Dune part 2 hits theaters on November
3rd 2023 with a few months to go before
its release fans have gotten a second
trailer to parse for hints as to how the
film will adapt to the Beloved sci-fi
classic there's plenty to chew on Dune
part 1 was dense with lore and came out
almost two full years ago with that in
mind if you have a fuzzy recollection of
what happened let us bring you back up
to speed since we'll be taking a deep
dive into the second trailer for part
two
it's not a prophecy it's a story The
Atreides family is a royal house with a
vast Galactic Dominion as a result of
their outstanding reputation and a
political move by the emperor they are
given the desert planet of Iraqis which
they can mine for one of the most
valuable resources in the universe spice
but not all is as it seems house
hearkenen which previously oversaw
arrakis launches a devastating surprise
attack that kills thousands including
Duke Leto atrates this leaves young
Paula trades and his mother lady Jessica
as seemingly the only survivors of the
royal family they must learn how to
survive the harsh deserts of Iraqis if
they hope to regain what they've lost
still things are not as dark as they may
seem Paul appears to be the figure at
the heart of two different Legends the
first is a calculated plan that the
Benny Jesuit have been overseeing for
centuries and the second is a prophecy
that the tribal fremen who Paul is
growing to lead believe with regard to
the young ruler who they call muadib now
with both prophecies seemingly coming
true Paul becomes a Messianic figure
with his new powers which include
foresight into the future he dreads that
he may leave the universe worse off than
he found it
you're really worth spreading across the
universe like unquenchable fire a
warrior religion that weighs you treat
his banner and my father's name
the biggest draw of the second Dune part
2 trailer is the reveal of Emperor
shadom IV brought to life by the
legendary Christopher Walken while
mentioned in the previous film The
Trailer gives us our first look at
Paul's Galaxy ruling adversary who will
play a key role in the sequel the
padisha emperor is the man that set the
events of Dune in motion grueling over
all of the known universe he fears
anything and anyone that threatens his
power unfortunately for House of tradies
Duke Leto was one such threat Leto's
growing popularity led shaddam to Grant
him control over arrakis using the
desert planet's wealth to disguise his
attack on House of Trades letto
understands that arrakis is a trap
when we get to Iraqis we'll face
enormous Danger
but he ultimately fails to defend his
house from the combined forces of
shaddam's sardicar and house harkinen
leading to his death and to Paul and
Lady Jessica's Exile into the desert in
Dune part 2 shaddam's secret plot
against house Atreides will come to a
head as he learns of Paul and Jessica's
survival and subsequent Rebellion with
the fremin eventually arriving on Iraqis
to confront them himself
in Dune part 2 Paul will be leading the
fremin and as a result the young Warrior
will see that the Harkins finally face
consequences for their disreputable
treatment of both House of Trades and
the natives of Iraqis fortunately for
Paul and the fremin house harkinen and
the emperor greatly underestimate their
threat not only do the fremen have a
better understanding of desert Warfare
than their Royal hosts but they also
have better battle stamina and the
ability to ride the massive sand worms
of arrakis the fremin also engage in
plenty of more traditional guerrilla
warfare as Paul chani and others are
seen launching fiery retaliatory strikes
in the duplicitous Harkins chani will
clearly play a big role in the fighting
plus her and stilgar's knowledge of
arakis's history and the ways of the
desert are key to Paul's struggle to
take back his rightful place in the
galaxy
Dune part 2 clearly features much more
Zendaya as chani after her lack of
screen time in the original disappointed
some fans her role looks to be even
bigger than an author Frank Herbert's
original novel director Denise
Villeneuve wasn't lying when he said he
wanted to make chani the protagonist of
part two in the trailer she and Paul are
in the spotlight as their growing
relationship will be the driving force
behind the sequel unlike in the book
chani will do more than just sit around
and wait for Paul to come home we see
her participating and maybe even leading
the fremin Rebellion against the
harkenings she decisively takes out a
member of The Emperor's sardicar in the
book Johnny's already a great fighter
but after training with Paul and Lady
Jessica she becomes a deadly Warrior it
looks like she's already there in Dune
part 2. although chani States she's
fighting for her people not Paul their
growing relationship will muddy those
Waters other developments including Paul
accepting his role as muadib put their
relationship to the test which Dune part
2 will likely showcase putting the
spotlight on Zendaya's performance as
Johnny
it is a very good time to be Dave
Batista the former WWE Superstar is
carving out a very impressive career in
Hollywood and his A-list status has led
to several collaborations with top
directors including denieville nov
Batista first worked with vilnov on
Blade Runner 2049 and the pair
reconnected for Dune part 1 with Batista
claiming the role of the sadistic glasu
Rabon harkinen he's reprising that role
for the sequel if the film's new trailer
is any indication the character may take
a bigger part in the action than he did
even in Herbert's Source material glossu
also known as the Beast was hardly a
minor player in Herbert's legendary
novel but he was largely sidelined after
leading Harkin and forces in their
attempt to destroy the whole of House
citrates part of his second act Arc
however is to seek out and kill the
desert dwelling fremin and if there's
room to expand the beast's journey in
Dune part 2 it may be in his mission to
cleanse the desert of Harkin and enemies
of course given Batista's Fame his
increased presence in the trailer may
just be a marketing move to build hype
but it could mean vilnove wanted to beef
up the role to make use of Batista's
seemingly boundless Talent if anyone can
help make a more three-dimensional
character of the Beast Batista is the
actor to do it
palatrady's place as the promised figure
of two separate prophecies isn't
necessarily the ray of desert sunshine
that it appears to be the further Paul
looks into the future with his powers
the worst things seem to get
because of all my Visions lead to horror
this is heavily reflected in the second
trailer for Dune part 2. Gurney holik
thinks Paul is afraid of losing control
but the young Atreides air points out
that he will instead gain power a power
so absolute that it will lead to the
deaths of millions of people across the
Galaxy no matter how he tries to wield
it these elements are some of the most
fascinating parts of Frank Herbert's
Dune novel this is a story about leading
during difficult times and trying to
pick the least bad of many increasingly
awful outcomes Dune reflects the
terrible consequences that follow any
Uprising based on religious belief
recalling many real-life Holy Wars such
as the Crusades so though this might
seem like a small part of the trailer
it's a massive part of the lore of the
series
a rapid series of shots in the trailer
goes from an extreme close-up of a
finger touching a blue liquid to Paul's
mother lady Jessica gasping as her eyes
glow blue before landing on an elderly
glossy-eyed woman who appears to be in
some sort of Trance well this sequence
lacks the context to mean anything to
fans who have only seen villnov's first
dune movie those familiar with its
source material or even David Lynch's
1984 adaptation will recognize this as a
major story beat that blue liquid is
called the Water of Life while normally
a poison through a ritual called spice
Agony a Benny Jester it like Jessica can
attain the powers of a reverend mother a
title granted to spiritual leaders who
have access to their ancestors memories
embedded in their genetic code the woman
in the third shot is the fremens current
Reverend mother Jessica's involvement in
the spice Agony ritual means big changes
are coming to the fremin social order
this key scene's inclusion in the film
likewise means that Paul's Place in the
fremin tribe as well as chani's role as
the member of the tribe closest to Paul
are going to become increasingly
complicated
throughout the trailer various
characters referred to Paul as Messiah
as the conclusion of the previous Dune
film makes clear Paul will have an
extremely important role to play in the
fremin tribe despite his Outsider status
the prophet why is that a bad thing use
it at one point in the trailer Paul
rides one of planetarakis's gargantuan
sand worms lady Jessica asks Foreman
leader stillgar if he believes in Paul
stillgar claims Paul is showing signs
presumably of being the fremin Messiah
as another shot of Paul Atop A sandworm
is shown on screen in the Dune Universe
writing sand worms is exclusively a
friend in practice and typically
something members of the tribe start
doing at a younger age than Paul
nevertheless he learns to ride a
sandworm despite his Advanced age and
unique background emphasizing that he's
right for the role of muadib following
this footage of Paul writing the sand
worm stillgar watches in awe suggesting
that Paul's worm writing competency is
one additional sign of his importance to
the fremin a little earlier in the
trailer chani is about to translate the
language for Paul before he stops her
having fully understood what was said to
him this drives home how rapidly he's
learning from and culture as a sandworm
rider then Paul is capable of one of the
hardest and most significant Feats
necessary for his acceptance into the
fremin of arrakis
foreign